[Music]
welcome back everyone is Charlie there's
huge news you probably just saw Zack
Snyder just announced that they're
releasing Justice League the Snyder cut
it's a real thing and it's gonna be
coming to HBO max as well explain all
the details what they're gonna be
changing in how the Snyder cut is
different from the theatrical cut so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos
obviously I will do a breakdown of the
Snyder cut when we actually get to watch
it because they're gonna be so many
different scenes and Easter eggs will do
a new Amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and let me
know in the comments what you want them
to add back into the movie before they
release it so first things first if you
don't know what happened this morning
Zack Snyder was just doing a regular
re-watch party for Man of Steel just
talking about behind the scenes details
what it was like to make the movie Henry
Cavill even Skyped in and was talking to
him during the broadcast answering
questions what his personal favorite
parts of the movie were to film and what
he really liked watching it because as
henry cavill said while they were doing
this rewatched party it's been a long
time since they filmed that and he's
actually ramping up to go back to do
witcher stuff zack snyder debunked a
couple popular fan theories about Man of
Steel like the Aquaman theory that
Aquaman was the one to save Superman
when he's passed out underwater so there
was some cool new details he revealed
about ban of steel but the real reason
everyone was hyped up about this
rewatched party is because everyone
believed that at the end of it he would
announce the Snyder cut but first thing
he actually said was that it wasn't up
to him to release it I would have done
it already if I could have but then also
was like yeah it's a real thing we're
gonna be releasing it during 2021 next
year
this is an official poster as you can
see they're calling it Zack Snyder's
Justice League it's gonna be available
in 2021 at some point and there's some
people saying that there might be some
minor reshoots because you may remember
last year zack snyder revealed that he
did have an assembly cut of his version
of justice league but what that means is
is that most of the special effects
hadn't been finished a lot of what was
just ten footage that didn't look
polished enough for an actual release
was being reported as the studio
spending about 20 million dollars to
bring all the actors back and then
finished post-production and rescore the
movie and it
to be a 4-hour single cut of the movie
like a regular movie or it'll be six
one-hour installments so you're either
getting a 4-hour cut or you're getting a
six-hour cut technically but it just
depends on how they decide to release it
either six installments or it's going to
be one giant four-hour chunk because
it's gonna take him about a year to
finish that new cut of the movie
presumably he's going to be talking
about the details and what kind of work
he's doing throughout the rest of this
year because a lot of that they can
actually do remotely even though the
virus is still a big thing a big problem
for everyone a couple years ago he
actually revealed what was in that
Snyder cut what his original plan was
for so I'll break down all the Snyder
cut changes that we know about all just
number these as we go along but the
first big thing is that his original cut
of the movie was closer to three and a
half hours we're talking longer than
Avengers endgame the theatrical cut was
right around two hours the studio
claimed at the time that about 80% of
that cut was still stuff the Zack Snyder
had filmed which i sweden shooting about
20% new footage and reshoots so mostly
what they lost was a ton of extra
storylines we're talking about an hour
and a half worth of footage so think
about how much stuff happened during
that that's like a whole other movie
inside the movie a lot of the big fight
scenes went down very differently the
color of the movie was very different
remember how we went from the first
trailer to the last trailer and how the
tone of the film the complete coloring
the backgrounds all seem like they
changed from start to finish like wait a
minute why is everything changing color
it was a ton more Superman Henry Cavill
stuff a ton more Aquaman Atlantis stuff
more Batman stuff more Wonder Woman the
Amazons backstory a ton more cyborg
scenes a ton more STAR Labs in the flash
in a ton a ton more Darkseid backstory
with some other subplots so for example
at the very beginning of the movie there
was no weird
Superman cell phone intro and Superman
didn't have to have his moustache
removed with bad special effects so it
actually looked like Henry Cavill like
this scene here is Zack Snyder henry
cavill footage this scene is stuff they
did during the reshoots with the bad cgi
mustache stuff originally the movie
opened with Batman and the parademons
learning about Darkseid's plants and the
other newer Justice League members each
getting extended intros and
backstories before they all came
together so like what we saw during that
original trailer from comic-con in 2016
with the extended scene of Batman trying
to recruit Aquaman went out completely
differently than the scene we saw in the
theatrical cut probably the biggest part
of the movie that changed though was
Henry cobbles Superman's storyline they
completely changed what was going on
with Superman in the movie remember the
scene of black suits Superman that was
part of that originally what was going
to happen is that Superman is
resurrected by the mother box but it's
Steppenwolf in Darkseid that bring him
back Pet Sematary style and early on in
the movie there was a lot more evil
angry Superman versus the fledgling
Justice League we got a little of that
during this big fight scene here but
imagine this times 10 for a lot longer
in the early parts of the film and while
this is all happening Superman was still
wearing the black suit remember all the
black suits Superman's stuff that we
felt like we were promised but then
never got that was big part of Zack
Snyder's Justice League they made a much
bigger deal of Steppenwolf's mother box
storyline the real reason in the
original cut that he was trying to
combine all those mother boxes is
because the cosmic soul of his mother
was trapped inside all three boxes he
wanted to free her and then take her
cosmic power using it to defeat dark
side and take apocalypse for himself
that's why he kept referring to mother
when he was talking to the mother boxes
if you thought that was weird
it's because his actual mother was
trapped inside the mother boxes there
was way more stuff going on with dark
sized history in the universe
Steppenwolf had been exiled by Darkseid
eons ago so taking all the mother boxes
on earth was Steppenwolf's play to get
back at Darkseid
the major flashback fight with the
combined forces of the Amazons the Greek
gods the Atlanteans in the humans was
supposed to be a fight against Darkseid
instead of Steppenwolf originally there
were going to be three Justice League
movies and a lot of the deleted scenes
the Zack Snyder filmed or was going to
film before he left the film were in
service of setting up storylines that
would pay off in the sequels there were
10 more scenes setting up Green Lantern
in the concept of the Green Lantern
Corps to which we would have seen more
of in the sequels remember the scene of
Superman meeting Alfred you must be
Alfred originally when they were still
doing a trilogy of movies this was going
be Hal Jordans green lantern showing up
before Zack Snyder left the project in
the studio had changed things again it
wound up being changed to Superman
showing up and eventually in the
theatrical cut the scene was removed
completely so there would have been some
Green Lantern Hal Jordan in the first
Justice League movie but just a little
bit in the theatrical cut they wound up
combining all this power plant stuff
with Steppenwolf's base in those scenes
originally those weren't meant to be the
same location Steppenwolf space was
separate from where this big power plant
was happening this family is something
that Joss Whedon added during the
reshoots Lois Lane was a bigger part of
the film early on but her storyline was
radically different so originally what
was going to happen is that in one of
the timelines Darkseid was gonna show up
and kill Lois Lane helping turn Superman
to the dark side using the anti-life
equation sort of bringing about Batman's
nightmare vision to pass so way darker
Lois Lane stuff going on when Aquaman
went back to Atlantis to get his armor
and his mother's trident there was a lot
more scenes with him talking to volcko
and Meera setting up the Aquaman
spin-off movie explaining more about why
he hated Atlantis so much and why the
Atlanteans didn't like him and at the
end of the movie when the Justice League
or fighting Steppenwolf he was always
going to be the main villain of the
first Justice League movie but there's
that scene of Superman with him at the
fortress of solitude the down Crotona
and ship switching back to his classic
red and blue suit the cool thing here is
that you actually get to see the
warframe from the comics this is what
the black suit actually looked like
Superman joins them they defeat
Steppenwolf together with a little
assist from Green Lantern and then
Steppenwolf gets sucked back to
apocalypse through the boom tube where
Darkseid winds up killing him later but
the Justice League are able to see
Darkseid's face from the other end
staring back at them meant to be a
teaser for Justice League two where the
plot started to turn more into what we
saw during the animated Justice League
apocalypse war movie if you didn't see
that animated movie they released it
just a little while ago I did a whole
video on it so I'll link that at the end
of this but the plot of that played out
a lot like Zack Snyder's original plans
when Justice League was going to be a
trilogy of movies is much bigger much
more epic much darker film but after the
Justice League learns about the threat
of Darkseid they wind up going to
epochal
getting their asses handed to them by
darkside darkside conquers earth
enslaving Superman using the anti-life
equation and at the end of the movie it
would have been very similar to the
ending of Avengers infinity war with the
snap all hope is lost the world has been
conquered
now the Snyder cut that they're
releasing next year on HBO max won't
have all of that stuff because that was
when it was still gonna be a trilogy
there will be way more deleted scenes
with all the characters though so it
should be pretty fun to check out but
I'm not expecting it to be released till
next spring at the earliest
but everyone post your reactions in the
comments below let me know what you want
them to add back in if you know about
some of the deleted scenes they cut and
everyone click here for my big video on
Justice League apocalypse war in the
ending of that movie and then click here
for my breakdown of the Batman teaser
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stays safe I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]